earlier today another batch of rambling
remarks from vice president harris
talking about the quote
passage of time during a speech in
louisiana sure this will keep you
riveted take a look the governor and i
and we were all
doing a tour of the library here
and um talking about the significance of
the passage of time
right the significance of the passage of
time
so when you think about it there is
great significance to the passage of
time in terms of what we need to do to
lay these wires what we need to do to
create these jobs and there is such
great significance to the passage of
time when we think about a day
in the life of our children
the passage of time ukraine is a country
in europe and it's next to a bigger
country uh called russia
and russia
invaded ukraine the smaller country
meanwhile we are also learning the vice
president's office just took their 10th
staffer that they lost since june this
time the national security adviser
fueling much more speculation about
internal strife and the inability of
staff to work with her also today on
capitol hill confirmation hearings
kicked off from biden's supreme court
nominee judge gatanji brown jackson
where she testified in front of the
senate saying her judicial role will be
constrained by careful adherence to
precedent despite her record suggesting
otherwise now republicans
appear poised to focus on judge
jackson's record and her judicial
philosophy instead of the smear tactics
and the circus that democrats
orchestrated against justice kavanaugh
back in 2018. here with reaction to all
this fox news speaker of the house fox
news contributor
newt gingrich so we got joe the
cognitive mess as president we got
kamala harris
it's kind of a disaster unfolding every
day and not far behind them is
uh the her own struggling
cognitive mess that is nancy pelosi so i
don't really have a lot of confidence in
the government right now mr speaker but
maybe i'm wrong you helped me out
well first of all if you want
a strong reason
to pray for the health of the present
united states
you are reminded again today
that that reason is the vice president
uh she's not only totally incoherent you
know he may or may not have cognitive
decline problems at his age
but at her age she's just dumb
i mean let's be clear kamala harris may
be the dumbest person ever elected vice
president in american history and that's
why people keep resigning i mean if you
were her national security advisor and
you were competent and you'd worked hard
and you knew what you were doing and you
watched her in poland
break up laughing when she's asked about
ukrainian refugees
you had to feel a sense of total
humiliation so i'm not surprised that
that particular advisor resigned
because it's very clear that kamala
harris should never ever be allowed to
leave the country
she probably shouldn't be allowed to
leave the naval observatory which is the
residence of the vice president uh she
is a conscious i don't know
herself and to the rest of us
i don't have confidence in either of
them
looking at the situation as it's
unfolding in ukraine now i talked about
the reagan doctrine i talked about the
trump doctrine and i've talked about
politicians that get us into endless
wars they start out gung-ho they don't
fight him to win the wars they
politicize the wars and then they pull
uh out our troops like in afghanistan um
after how many you know thousands of
americans are dead and how many
thousands of other americans have
incredible injuries we can't do this
anymore mr speaker can we
well look i think there are things we
can do exactly as you described earlier
with reagan who as you know i worked
with all throughout his eight years as
president
one
we could give the ukrainians
ship killing missiles which would drive
the russian fleet away from the
ukrainian coast
two we could give the ukrainians cruise
missiles and surface-to-surface missiles
and make a clear statement if the
russians are going to bomb civilians we
have every right to bomb uh
have the ukrainians have the equipment
to bomb airfields missile sites missile
storages that would change the game
almost overnight
i think third we ought to recognize that
we need to state
very clearly this is the number one job
joe biden has when he goes to europe
this week we need to state very clearly
that if you start using chemical weapons
we will respond within hours the
response will be overwhelming and you
will be decisively defeated sometime in
the next 48 hours after you use them we
cannot
relax and allow putin to continue to be
a war criminal who thinks he can get
away with anything because the american
president is too timid and too cautious
uh to do anything and i'll say also i'm
told by people who are pretty well
informed that the national security
adviser is a major problem because he
keeps slowing down all the things that
need to be going to ukraine he ought to
be fired and replaced by somebody who'd
actually like to defeat putin in new
claim in in ukraine not help him win
all right mr speaker thank you for being
with us appreciate it smart maybe you
can be president
we need somebody job's wide open
nobody's really paying attention there
or knows what they're doing when we come
back the mob the media facing widespread
backlash after being forced to admit
hunter biden's laptop was not a hoax
unfortunately most of them still are
hiding and won't admit their error